we are at the beginning of a new era
personal computing is being redefined as
the technology around us becomes a part
of who we are
this is the wearable revolution
we put technology on our bodies to make
ourselves better
to find a way to kind of move through
the world and extend ourselves
looking around for a name we came up
with wearable computing it's a wearable
tech revolution and one of the big
talking points this year is wearable
technology wearable electronics their
wearable technology offerings at this
year's consumer electronics show
wearables 2014 is said to be the year of
wearable tech electronics that are
physically attached to your body but
what good is that why does anyone even
want that well to put a super long story
super simple and short in 2007 apple
reinvented the smartphone with the new
iphone and made a lot of money off of
that now everyone has a smartphone so
now companies are scrambling to find the
next big thing the next big paradigm
shift that will make the first good one
a lot of money and they all seem to
think it's going to be something
wearable and i guess that seems kind of
cool you know having glanceable
information without taking your phone
out your pocket not that it's all that
much effort to do that but a watch is
already perfect for that you can just
glance and look at the time without
having to unlock your phone but what if
it was something more what if it was
something a little smarter than that
something that could actually show
information from your phone or your
phone's notifications or what if it gets
to the point where in a couple months or
years you can take out your phone and
say okay google now set a timer for 10
minutes
and in 10 minutes the timer goes off on
your wrist so these first bits of
wearable tech we're seeing here in 2014
it's still january are very beta they're
the very first look at the attempt to be
an iphone of this wearable realm and
we're seeing a lot of weird stuff but
hopefully this list will be very
different by the end of 2014 hence the
title of this video so without any
further ado here are the top five best
wearable options we have right now
number five is a qualcomm talk smart
watch now this is a really interesting
device for a lot of reasons but number
one is definitely its display it's
called a mirasol display it's a pretty
new technology that qualcomm's thrown
into this that gives it incredible
outdoor viewing ability it's it's got
great viewing angles great brightness it
looks like basically paper and you can
view it outside no matter how the
reflections are shining off of this
thing so the display is really
interesting about it but the thing is
it's not really a problem but qualcomm
isn't a hardware manufacturer they don't
they don't do the entire device they do
the insides and the guts of devices so
you can see that with the talk the
design is not there this is not an easy
to use smart watch it's not intuitive
the ui isn't good there's all sorts of
confusing and redundant bits about it
and uh that would be the downside of
owning this thing there's a big learning
curve and it's at the end of the day
not really that much faster than just
taking your phone out your pocket number
four is the samsung galaxy gear another
take on the smartwatch and this one i
have to say is easily one of the
classiest and best looking smart watches
out there it has a battery life that
lasts about two days or so with regular
use and it's got a whole bunch of
different watch faces and it's it's
overall just really appealing it's
probably the best looking accessory
samsung makes to any of its stuff
but that's the thing the huge downside
is that this is an accessory to a
samsung product it only works with less
than a dozen devices right now and if
you don't have one of those dozen the
samsung galaxy note 3 or the galaxy s4
or one of their new tablets or something
like that it's really just a watch not a
smart watch it's just the watch face you
can't do anything and even if you do
have one of those new samsung devices a
lot of the notifications aren't really
full featured it'll only tell you that
you have a new notification you should
probably check your phone now what's the
point of that if you're gonna take your
phone out your pocket anyway overall the
gear is a very confined device it feels
very throttled by the fact that samsung
wants to have control over the entire
experience number three is the google
glass explorer edition one of the only
ones on this list that's not on your
wrist and honestly it's really
interesting technology it's essentially
a heads up display to real life you
constantly have a display and a camera
across your face and every time you wear
it you have that sort of instant access
to actual notifications from your ios or
android device now the fact that you're
wearing it on your face means they have
to keep it lightweight so it doesn't
have a very large battery but the real
downside is that when you're wearing it
you look like this
and that makes a lot of people
uncomfortable when you have a camera on
your face all the time and you're
looking around at people and some people
just don't like it at all it makes them
uncomfortable and also it's 1500 bucks
which is another downside but that will
hopefully be changing very soon when
this year 2014 we see the full consumer
edition of google glass because this
explorer edition is a limited edition
product and you can see my video about
that right below the like button but
essentially this is a beta test number
two is fitbit and we're going back to
the wrist here but the fitbit force is
actually really cool it's an awesome
product it's essentially a fitness band
and it does everything under the moon it
tracks a whole bunch of things about
your daily activity and about your
nightly activity works on any android or
ios device with bluetooth 4.0 and above
and there are plenty of other fitness
bands there is a nike fuel band there's
the lg lifeband touch the jawbone up a
whole bunch of other things that do the
similar things that this fitbit does but
in different combinations but the fitbit
really does everything it does all of
the things during the day your dieting
the amount of steps you take a pedometer
an activity tracker calories burned and
even a sleep timer and the sleep
activity tracker so all these different
things put together in one package that
let you look back upon your day and see
exactly what you did and try to beat the
goals and beat your friends goals you
can sync up and accumulate points
there's a whole bunch of awesome stuff
that goes along with this wearable tech
it doesn't necessarily deliver
information to you it doesn't
necessarily talk to your phone or give
extra glanceable value but when you take
it off at the end of the day and plug it
into your computer there's a whole bunch
of awesome stuff that goes on and number
one there's one company that's taking a
very focused approach to it all it's the
only company on this list that only does
wearable tech and that's pebble this
company pebble started with a very
successful kickstarter project where
they did the first iteration of the
pebble smartwatch and now recently at
ces they showed off the second iteration
called pebble steel but more importantly
they also now have a very specific app
store for pebble because of all the
third-party sites that we're doing this
anyway and pebble has the advantage of
being able to focus a hundred percent
dedication on this smart watch concept
because that is all they do and then the
pebble doesn't necessarily do everything
under the sun it won't do every little
function that the galaxy gear does with
the camera or the taking and receiving
voice calls but the things that it does
do it does very very well and that's
what pebble prides themselves in the new
app store that they're putting together
will allow even more functionality with
the device because of all the things
that people can build into the apps now
to talk to your smartphone so glanceable
information will probably be at its best
on a pebble so there you go those are
your top five wearable tech available
right now i do want to give some
honorable mentions to some stuff that i
saw at ces two smart bands the jaybird
rain and the razer nabu these are things
that actually have some unique
functionality that other fitness bands
don't have right now so i want to see
those come out this year and there's
also way more really interesting
wearable stuff there's something called
optinvent aura which is supposedly the
next best google glass competitor it's
not a private product so it's public so
you can buy it and see what that's like
i might want to try that out and also
there is the neptune pine which is a
standalone smart watch so you don't need
it to be connected to the phone it's
actually just a mini android tablet and
it gives you all the information you
need and there's also stuff like oculus
rift which i also tried for the first
time at ces technically this isn't near
the sort of wearable stuff we're talking
about with google glass or the smart
watches but technically it's wearable
and technically speaking this is an
incredible experience like totally
objectively this is one of the most
immersive things you can have even if
you're not a huge gamer like me it's
pretty cool to play with and an
interesting admission from all this is
apple which again is why the video title
is what it is because i think by the end
of this year we're going to see way more
wearable stuff from big companies like
apple like intel maybe even google will
make a smart watch with the same
interface as google glass i think that
would work out really well so keep an
eye on all the stuff we make videos
about here on the mkbhd channel as well
as if you want to follow me on twitter
i'll be sharing a whole bunch of the
more awesome stuff that comes out and
appears on the market but that's been it
thank you for watching this video and i
will talk to you guys in the next one
peace
you